I made this decision about 18 months ago
shonda rhimes wrote me off scandal
Portia de Rossi says she actually quit
acting about a year and a half ago but
she's still appearing in the upcoming
fifth season of Arrested Development
you're running for office I'm gonna be
part of the problem Michael so how did
that happen
Portia stopped by her wife Ellen
DeGeneres's show on Wednesday and
admitted she's not really sure how she
ended up on the small screen again I
called Mitch Horowitz who's the creator
of Arrested Development and I said if
there is a season five I won't be doing
it because I quit acting and he seemed
really like understanding and he totally
got it we had a great conversation and
then he wrote me into five episodes
don't know how it happened but yes I am
on season five while the actress will
officially say goodbye to her craft
after the season drops on Netflix May
29th she's still working shifting gears
as the owner of general public and art
curation and publishing company the
decision to try something new came
around her 45th birthday Ellen joked
that Portia was aging out of roles I
just was wondering is there something
that I could tackle now that I've never
done before that would be really
challenging and different and I kind of
knew what acting would look like for me
for the next 10 20 years
so so I decided to quit and start a
business
you